what i want to do in this video is give
an introduction to the language or some
of the some of the some of the
characters that we use when we talk
about geometry and i guess the best
place to start is even think about what
geometry means is you might recognize
the first part of geometry right over
here you have the root word geo the same
word that you see in things like
geography and geology and this comes
this refers to the earth
this refers my e look like a c right
over there this refers to the earth
and then you see this metry part and you
see metric in things like trigonometry
as well and metri or the metric system
and this comes from measurement
this comes from measurement or measure
measurement so when someone's talking
about geometry the word itself comes
from earth measurement and that's kind
of not so bad of a name because it is
such a general subject geometry really
is
the study and and trying to understand
how shapes and space and and and things
that we see relate to each other so you
know when when you start learning about
geometry you learn about lines and
triangles and circles and you learn
about angles and we'll define all of
these things more and more precisely as
we go further and further on but also
encapsulate things like patterns and and
three-dimensional shapes so it's almost
everything that we see ever all the math
visually mathematical things that we
understand can in some way be
categorized in geometry now with that
out of the way let's just start from the
basics a basic starting point from
geometry and then we can just grow from
there so if we just start at a dot
that dot right over there it's just a
point it's just that that little point
on that screen right over there we'd
literally call that a point and i'll
call that a definition and the fun thing
about mathematics is that you can make
definitions you we could have called
this and we could have called this an
armadillo but we decided to call this a
point which i think makes sense because
it's what we would call it in just
everyday language as well that is a
point now what's interesting about a
point
is that it is just a position that you
can't move on a point if you moved if
you were at this point and if you moved
in any direction at all you would no
longer be at that point so you cannot
move on a point now there are
differences between points for example
that's one point there maybe i have
another point over here and then i have
another point over here and then another
point over there and you want to be able
to refer to the different points and not
everyone has the luxury of a nice
colored pen like i do otherwise they
could refer to the green point or the
blue point or the pink point and so in
geometry to refer to points we tend to
give them labels and the labels tend to
have letters so for example this could
be point a this could be point b this
would be point c and this right over
here could be point d so someone says
hey circle point c you know which one to
circle you know that you would have to
circle you would have to circle that
point right over there well that so far
it's kind of interesting you have these
things called points you really can't
move around on a point all they do is
specify a position what if we want to
move around a little bit more what if we
want to get from one point to another so
what if we took we started at one point
and we wanted to c we wanted all of the
points including that point that connect
that point in another point so all of
these points right over here
so what would we call what would we call
this thing all of the points that
connect a and b along a straight and
i'll use everyday language here along
kind of a straight line like this well
we'll call this a line segment in
everyday language you might call it a
line but we'll call it a line segment
because we'll see in g when we talk in
mathematical terms a line means
something slightly different
so this is a line segment
and if we were to connect d and c this
would also be another line segment
a line segment
and once again because then we always
don't have the luxury of colors this one
is clearly the orange line segment this
is clearly the yellow line segment we
want to have labels for these line
segments and the best way to label the
line segments are with its end points
and that's another word here so a point
is just literally
a or b but a and b are also the end
points of these line segments because it
starts and ends at a and b
so let me write this a and b
a
and b
are end points
another definition right over here we
once again we could have called them
aardvarks or end armadillos but we as
mathematicians decide to call them
endpoints because that seems to be a
good name for it and once again we need
a way to label these line segments with
that have the endpoints and what's a
better way to label a line segment than
with its actual endpoints so we would
refer to this line segment over here we
would put its endpoints there and to
show that it's a line segment we would
draw a line over it just like that this
line segment down here we would write it
like this
and we could have just as easily written
it like this c d with a line over it
would have referred to that same line
segment
ba ba with a line segment with a line
over it would refer to that same line
segment
now you might be saying well i'm not
satisfied just traveling in between a
and b and this is actually another
interesting idea when you were just on a
when you're just on a point and you
couldn't travel at all you couldn't
travel all in any direction without
while staying on that point that means
you have you have zero options to travel
in you can't go up or down left or right
in or out of the page and still be on
that point and so that's why we say a
point has zero dimensions
zero dimensions now all of a sudden we
have this thing this line segment here
and this line segment we can at least go
to the left and the right along this
line segment we can go towards a or
towards b so we can go back or forward
in one dimension so the line segment is
a one dimensional
it is a one dimensional idea almost or
one dimensional object although these
are more kind of abstract ideas there is
no such thing as a perfect line segment
because everything a line segment you
can't move you can't move up or down on
this line segment while being on it
while in reality anything that we think
is a line segment even you know a a a a
a stick of some type a very state
straight stick or a string that is
taught that still will have some width
but the geometrical pure line segment
has no width it only has a length here
so you can only move along the line and
that's what we say it's one dimensional
a point you can't move at all a line
segment you can only move in that back
and forth along that same direction
now i just hinted that it can actually
have a length
how do you refer to that well you refer
to that by not writing that line on it
so if i write a b with a line on top of
it like that that means i'm referring to
the actual line segment if i say that
let me do this in a new color if i say
that a b
is equal to five
units it might be centimeters or meters
or whatever just the abstract units five
that means that the distance between a
and b is five that the length of
line segment a b is actually 5. now
let's keep on extending it let's say we
want to just keep going in one direction
so let's say that i started a let me do
this in a new color let's say i started
a and i want to go to d but i want to i
want the option of keep on i want to
keep on going so i can't go further in
a's direction than a but i can go
further in d's direction so this little
this this this idea that i just showed
this essentially it's like a line
segment but i can keep on going past
this end point we call this
we call this a ray and the starting
point for array is called the vertex not
a term that you'll see too often you'll
see vertex later on in other contexts
but it's good to know this is the vertex
of of the ray it's not the vertex of
this line segment so maybe i shouldn't
label it just like that
and what's interesting about array it's
once again a one dimensional figure but
you could keep on going in one of the
direct you can keep on going toward past
one of the endpoints and the way that we
would specify array is we would say
we would call it a d and we would put
this little arrow over on top of it to
show that it is array and in this case
it matters the order that we put the
letters in if i put d a
if i put d a as array this would mean a
different ray that would mean that we're
starting at d and then we're going past
a so this is not ray d a this is ray a d
now the last idea that i'm i'm sure
you're thinking about is well what if i
could keep on going in every in both
directions so let's say i can keep going
in let me my diagram is getting messy so
let's let me introduce some more points
so let's say i have point e and then i
have point f right over here and let's
say that i have this object
that can that goes through both e and f
but just keeps on going in both
directions this is when we talk in
geometry terms this is what we call a
line now notice a line never ends you
can keep going in either direction a
line segment does end it has end points
a line does not and actually a line
segment can sometimes be called just a
segment and so you would specify line ef
you would specify line ef
with these arrows just like that now the
thing that you're going to see most
typically when we're studying geometry
are these right over here because we're
going to be concerned with sides of
shapes distances between points
and we're talking about any of those
things things that have finite length
things that have an actual length things
that don't go off forever in one or two
directions then you're talking about a
segment or a line segment now if we go
back to a line segment just to kind of
keep talking about new words that you
might confront in geometry if we go back
talking about a line that's i was
drawing a ray so let's say i have point
x and point y
and so this is line segment x y so i can
specify it denote it just like that if i
have another point
let's say i have another point right
over here let's call that point z
and i'll introduce another word
x y and z are on the same they all lie
on the same line if you would imagine
that a line could keep going on and on
forever and ever so we can say that x y
and z are co-linear
so those three points are co
they are co-linear they all sit on the
same line or and they also all sit on
line segment x y
now let's say we know we're told that x
z
is equal to z y
and they are all collinear so that means
this is telling us that the distance
between x and z is the same as the
distance between z and y
so sometimes we can we can mark it like
that this distance is the same as that
distance over there so that tells us
that z is exactly halfway between x and
y so in this situation we would call z
the midpoint the midpoint
of
of line segment x y because it's exactly
halfway between
now to finish up we've talked about
things that have zero dimensions points
we've talked about things that have one
dimension a line a line segment or ray
you might say well what has two
dimensions well in order to have two
dimensions that means i can go backwards
and forwards in two different directions
so
this this page right here or this video
or the screen that you're looking at is
a two-dimensional object i can go i can
go right left that is one dimension or i
can go up down and so this this pl this
this this this surface of the monitor
you're looking at is actually two
dimensions two dimensions you can go
backwards or forwards in two directions
and things that are two dimensions we
call them planar or we call them planes
so if you took a if you took a a piece
of paper that extended forever just it
just extended in every direction forever
that in the geometrical sense was a
plane the piece of paper itself the
thing that's finite and you'll never see
this talked about in a in a typical
geometry class but i guess if we were to
draw the analogy you could call a piece
of paper maybe a plain segment because
it's a segment of an entire plane if you
had a third dimension then you're
talking about kind of our
three-dimensional space in
three-dimensional space not only could
you move left or right along the screen
or up and down you could also move in
and out of the screen you could also
have this dimension that i'll try to
draw you could go into the screen or you
could go
out of the screen like that and and as
we go into higher and higher mathematics
although it becomes very hard to
visualize you'll see that we can even
start to study things that have more
than three dimensions